[Music]
things seem to be heating up between
Jason Momoa and Aza Gonzalez from the
looks of it the rumored couple's romance
seems to be revving up again
check out Aza hopping on the back of
Jason's Harley for a motorcycle ride
with the wind in her hair ASA grips
Jason pretty tight around the waist as
he takes the actress for a joy ride
through Malibu's Topanga Canyon he's
trying to be a gentleman so could Jason
and Aza be rekindling their romance well
according to an eyewitness the two met
up pretty late the day before and
weren't seen again until the next day as
they headed out to get some fresh air of
course this isn't the first time Jason
and Aza have been linked in May E.T
confirmed the duo was dating but the
fling ended quickly when they split one
month later in June at the time A source
told E.T the relationship was always
pretty casual apparently the actors had
their schedules to blame for the end of
their romance quote they're both busy in
their own lives and with work so it's
difficult to have a serious relationship
but they do still enjoy each other's
company and like each other judging by
this sighting fans are speculating they
could be more than friends we just hope
this outing went smoother than Jason's
last earlier this week the Aquaman star
was involved in a head-on collision with
the motorcyclist who veered into Jason's
Lane while he was driving his vintage
car thankfully Jason walked away
unharmed and the motorcyclist only had
minor injuries and Jason and aza's
latest outing proves at least one thing
safety always comes first
[Music]